I know that you're a huge Star Wars fan
yes and and you it's almost like a
religion with you how excited are you
they're gonna be 55 more Star Wars not
over the next 700 you know what as long
as they as long as they they take the
time on the script and do it right I'm
excited I'm a huge fan how big a fan are
you is it true that you were building an
r2d2 robot in your home and that's not
even a joke is that true that your
builder no that's such a yes of a no it
sounds like it's already built yeah it's
it's halfway done we could call your
house right now and it would answer it's
it's running security of my house
I am I I joined this online site and I
am very coolly happy to say that I am
myself building in r2d2 I mean you're
building an RT so there's a site where
they send you the parts to build a real
r2d2 yes I like your answer that yes
bond James will it work will it actually
do things we'll see I wasn't one of
those that was like good with
remote-control cars when I was a kid so
I don't know any but now you're building
our human humanoid robot it's true yeah
that's fantastic
yeah it may not work at all but it'll be
fun to to try it when you're done verily
I'm not working much
[Laughter]
my cable now it's looking I'm doing 10
episodes of a show a year or every two
years so I have I have time so I'm on
cable and r2d2 is for anybody here any
now you're building a c-3po it's done
new heading band premieres Saturday
night at 10:00 on TBS I want to see this
robot when you're done wait you I'm
serious I'll bring it back I'm gonna
bring it here and then I'll wear the
t-shirt ride in it how about that
what whoa whoa I won't call back
I'm six four and a half I've never get
in that thing how bad is what's funny
about it my head came out the top yeah